COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some garden lovers
with their deployment times.
Are we potting fake plants?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Rainmages is a company
that has a robust back end
system with lots of small
microservices, each one powered
by Google Cloud Functions.
They ran into an issue.
Doing 200 or so code
deployments a day,
their team was wasting
a lot of time waiting
for code to be moved around.
Digging in, one of the
first things we noticed
was that each GCF
for each microservice
had a different set
of dependencies.
And where they were using
the same dependency,
chances are they weren't
using the same versions.
This threw a massive red flag.
As versions of each dependency
vary across deployments,
dependency cache misses
are much more likely,
meaning the deployment
times will be longer.
We were able to unify
the instances to use
all of the same
versions of a library,
meaning they were more likely
to be in the dependency cache,
making deployments
a little faster.
Second, I noticed a few
interesting statistics
with respect to their
deployment setup.
It looked as though they were
shipping a lot of extra files,
around 600 or so extra
config and data files.
They would then fetch these
files from the local GCS bucket
that their function
stuff was deployed into.
While this makes managing
microservice deployments
easier, it was killing
their deployment times.
Instead, we pushed
their extra data
to a separate cloud
storage bucket,
so that uploads can
happen in parallel
and were shared in
some cases, resulting
in another great
performance boost.
If you'd like to know
more about our work
to fix deployment times,
check out the article
linked the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]